bir tanem
ve 1990'lı yılların ortalarında bir bey
Ankara'da Başbakanlığın önüne gitti ve
kapıdaki güvenlik görevlisine
başbakanlığı devralmaya geldim dedi bunu
yatıran var mı aranızda Evet tektik
sosyal medya Bu kadar yaygın olmadığı
için 1990'larda çok da duyulmadı
Muhtemelen Fakat bu ve gerçekten
kendisini Başbakan hissediyordu öyle
algılıyor du ve onun için oradaydı
Bugünlerde daha sık rastlanıyor
insanların kendini başka türlü
hissettiklerini fark ettikleri anladı
itibaren internete bakıp Ben bir polarım
galiba ya da işte ben manik depresif
şimdiye karşımıza gelmeleri os o kadar
kolay değil
bu ipler bozukluk bir hastalık ama
insanın ruh hali de dalgalanır olduğu
yerde durmaz Nitekim o grafikte
görüyorsunuz ruh halimiz
Çok keyifli ile keyifsiz arasındadır
mesela Muhtemelen Ben yüzünüze
baktığımda bir saat önce baksaydım çok
ayırt edemezdim keyfi misiniz keyifli
keyifsiz misiniz Ama bir önceki
konuşmadan sonra gayet keyifli
görünüyorsunuz ama yine de bilemeye
bilirim böyle görünürsünüz ama başka bir
şey hissediyorsunuz dur işte biz buna
olan ruh hali diyoruz olan ruh halimiz
kendi içinde değişir Her gün bazen
olağandan daha coşkulu oluruz bir şey
çok seviniriz
bu Piyangodan para çıkar bir şey olur
bir sebebi vardır ya da bir şey çok
üzülürüz o zaman da kederli oluruz bir
süre bunların da bir sebebi vardır hiç
sebepsiz olduğunda
Bu işin içinde bir iş var diye düşünmek
gerekiyor
de bunun daha fazlası yani coşkulu dan
da daha fazlası artık Taşkın bir hal Oh
al öyle çok kolay daha yol edilir bir
şey değil Eğer Taşkın ya deseniz işte
Ankara'da başbakanlığı devralmaya geldim
diyebilirsiniz kolayca ya da tam tersi
çok çok gün bir halde olabilirsiniz o
kadar çok gün o kadar kendinizi kötü ve
değersiz hissediyorsunuz dur ki hatta
suçlu hissediyorsunuz dur ki las eski
dünyadaki bütün kötülüklerin sebebi
benim aslında gördüğünüz gibi Taşkın ya
da çökün olmak çok kolay değil Peki
olunca dünyanın salgılanıyor derseniz
işte bunun örneğini ve çırp girme
stragon filminde versin önce dokuzuncu
Senfonisi ile betofının başlar betofının
dokuzuncu Senfoni neşeye özgü kısmı
abone ol
ki bunda coş kullanmamaya imkan yok
çünkü çok yakışıklı bir şey zaten öküz
desen küp ama ne kadar Coşkun olursanız
olun ve Selanik final önünde kendinizi
atıp zubin mehta gibi davranmaya
çalışmazsanız yerde işte taşkınlık böyle
birşeye öyle bir şey olduğunda da biraz
yüzünü bir sonucu var bu
daha sonra aynı kişiyi Bu kez Türk'ün
halde görüyoruz kederli değil üzgün
değil keyifsiz değil ama çok gül
gerçekten depresif kendini değersiz işe
gelemez ölse de kurtulsak hiçbir şey
farketmeyecek ne olursa olsun ruh hali
içinde görebiliriz kolayca
bu işte ben size bu hallerde ki insanlar
dünyayı nasıl algılarlar konusunu birkaç
örnek vereyim Örneğin şu her zamanki ruh
halini esas alalım ve her zamanki ruh
hali için mesela büyük bir şairin Nazım
Hikmet'in bir şiiri ne bakalım Nazım
Hikmet'in ömrü cezaevlerinde sürgünlerde
perişan bir şekilde geçti ama Nazım
Hikmet bütün o perişanlığı içinde
yaşamak ne güzel şey anasını sattığımın
yaşamak ne güzel şey yani olağan ruh
hali içinde onun o coşkulu ya da keyifli
halini algılayabiliyor Uz Uz taşkınlık
ise bambaşka bir şey Taşkın olan kişi
Evet yok falan mide yön etmeye
çalışabilir yahut peygamber Mehdi
Superman olduğunu düşünebilir
şu an o kadar uzağa da gitmemiz
gerekiyor veya bir Hastam İstanbul'dan
Eskişehir'e yürüyerek gittiğini
söylemişti
Sen neden dedim çünkü yapabilirsiniz
dedi o yapabilirlik duygusu a o Taşkın
ruh hali içindeki algısıyla onun ya da
askerdeyken adına Mehmet diyelim Mehmet
yatırmıştım mani tablosuyla hastaneye
kapalı servisimiz yoktu açık servisimiz
Hadi poliklinikte hasta görürken
Dışarıdan sesler geldi ve önceden baktım
bizim Mehmet bir tane Üsteğmenin yolunu
kesmiş omzuna Üç tane yıldız çizmiş yok
ki ben senin üstünüm niye bana selam
vermiyorsun
en korkunç bir şey askerler için ya da
başka bir örnek vereyim bir hasta
hastaneye getirildiğinde katatoni yani
donakalma halindedir Öykü şöyle
gelişmiştir bu kişi otobüsten iner
adımını atar ve öyle kalır
ve hemen ambulans çağırıp hastaneye
götürmek zorunda kalırlar tedavi
tamamlanır 20 gün sonra çıkar o çıkarken
doktorlar ya da tedavi süreci içinde
sorarlar yani tamam Bu tabloyu anladık
bu adamın bir bipolar bozukluğu var bir
mani tablosu katuni tablosu içinde
gelmiş ve keman niye orada kaldın Çünkü
belki Adam tam adımımı attım Bir baktım
dünyanın ortasından geçen çizgiye
basıyorum bu tarafa adım atsam dünya bu
tarafa devrilecek bu tarafa adım atarsam
dünya öbür tarafa devrilecek kalakaldım
bu aşkın algısı ya da diplerdeki algı
böyle bir şey ve bu o kadar sıranın
sıradan olağan halin içine sığmayacak
bir şey aynı zamanda ya da daha günlük
hayatta da karşımıza çıkıveriyor Mesela
bir zaman zaman hastalarımıza resim
yaptırırız biz kendilerini en iyi ifade
ettikleri resimleri bir hastamız
kendisine en iyi ifade ettiği resmi
yapıp altına imzasını atmış Kazım Kartal
diyelim şaşıracak bir şey yok gibi
görünüyor birde Kartal çizmiş fakat
hastamızın adı Kasım Serçe
bu çökkünlük sıvının tam tersi Ayna
görüntüsü adeta ve çökün kişi adeta
yağmurun sadece kendi başının üzerine
aldığını düşünüyor bir sis bulutu içinde
yürüyorum dünya dayım ama dünyaya hiçbir
ilişkim yok o kadar berbat vaziyetteyim
ki yok olsam kimsenin umurunda olmaz ya
da benim iç organlarım bile çürümüş
Aslında ben yokum yok oluyorum hissi bu
çok anlaşılabilir bir şey değil ama
bakın Az evvel en Zorlu zamanlarında
yaşamak ne güzel şey diyen Büyük şair
diyor ki ne çürüyen etimden haberim
olacak ne gözlerimin Çukurunda dolaşan
böceklerden durup dinlenmeden ölümü
düşünüyorum sıram yakın demek bu onun
yaş dönümü depresyonunu çök günlüğüne o
zaman kağıdı uydu çok
en iyi anlatan bir örnek Aslında Nitekim
Kendisi de bir bipolar bozukluk hastası
olan dünyanın belki en önemli
isimlerinden diyebilirim Amerikalı
psikoloji profesörü seyret yok James'in
diyor ki depresyonları ve basit bir şey
değildir yani boşandınız işinizi
kaybettiniz falan diye depresyona
girdiğinizi sanırsınız umutsuzluk sadece
depresyon gerçekte düz sığ ve dayanılmaz
bir şey bununla yaşanamaz çökkünlük çok
günlükteki algı böyle bir şey aslında da
sonra
Evet her zamanki ruh haline geri döner
Erkişi bu sefer yıldız koydu Çünkü her
zamanki ruh haline geri döndüğünde bütün
o dönemler yaşanmıştır Evet her zamanki
ruh halindedir Ama artık bambaşka bir
şey bambaşka bir algıyla dünyaya
bakıyordur kişi Mesela bir astığımız ve
demişti ki ben üniversite mezunu inançlı
biriyim uykusuzluğum vardı sonra giderek
arttı kendimi çok özel hissettim sonra
televizyonu açtım Melih Gökçek benden
bahsediyorum adım Ahmet Mehdi'nin adının
Ahmet olduğunu bulacağım ve İstanbul'u
feth edeceğini de biliyordum bu görev
bana verilmişti Evet beğendim sonra
tedavi olur tabii tedaviden sonraki
algısı şu şimdi Hepsi bitti ne
yapacağımı bilemiyorum sık sık aklıma
geliyor O gerçekse Bu neydi Bu gerçekten
o kadar inanmış ki şimdi unu kaybetmek
belki de o büyük Coşkun'un kaybının yazı
aynı zamanda bir başka Aslan demişti ki
ben evdeki de depresyon döneminde bütün
ilişkiler o kadar bozulmuş ki işte
Eskiden benim ne dersem o yapılırdı Evin
patronu beğendim vesaire depresyondan
çıktım Bütün dengeler bütün ile miktar
değişmiş ve bu yeni dünya ya uyum
sağlamak zorunda değil bir baş Kastamonu
nasılsın dediğim dedi ki 2 litre kola
içebildiği kadar Kahve içiyorum Hayal
etmeye çalıştım korkunç bir şey tüketimi
neden
bu çünkü dedi ben herşeyi denedim
hayatta esrar kokain herşeyi denedim
Fakat bu maninin kafası bunların
Hiçbirinde yok onu tekrar elde etmeye
çalışıyorum yapabilirsem
iyi Sonuç olarak nesnelere olduğu gibi
değil olduğumuz gibi görürüz diyor tamam
mı da atfedilen birçok başka yazarında
söz ettim en çok annesinin meşhur ettiği
gücüne gerçekten İçinde bulunduğumuz
durumda dünyayı o biçimiyle algılıyoruz
olduğu gibi değil olduğunuz gibi bende
dünyayı barış ve kardeşlik içinde algıla
Yalım hip teşekkür ederim